I'm going to show you in this video five
ways to get property deals off the
market that means you're going to be
finding deals that are not on right move
they're not on zoopla you're going to be
going to some secret places completely
off the market to get the best property
investment deals in the UK in 2022. so
the five ways I'm going to show you the
first way is find Properties by land
registry what do I mean by that well the
best type of property deals are usually
properties that are run down it's
hideous you can add significant value
too but if you see a property on right
move and it's run down all the
developers are going to see it they're
going to start viewing it from all
across the country so what I do and what
I'd recommend you do too is when you're
just driving around if ever you see a
property that's overgrown or there's
bushes all around it stop in your car
take a photograph of it and take down
the door number and the address then
when you get home I do this all the time
go on land registry there's an online
portal on land registry where you can
put the address in you can pay three
pounds and it will give you the full
address it will give you the owner's
details who owns it how long it's been
owned all the information you can look
at the flood risk planning it planning
portals do all your research but the
property isn't even on the market but if
it's run down it's derelict and it's
been abandoned chances are if you then
reach out to the owner because you've
got the details on land registry because
you paid three pounds you reach out to
the owner they're probably going to be
open to a sale and then you're not
competing against 20 investors all
bidding because you're the person that
contact them Direct that's the first why
however there's five by the way if you
like my channel if you're enjoying this
hit the like button okay that would
really help me out the second way is
find off-market deals that are not on
right move through estate agents now you
might be thinking well hang on a minute
if it's through an estate agent then
surely the property's on the market
wrong most of my deals that come off
Market actually come through estate
agents Let Me Explain how contact estate
agents tell them what you're looking for
show them your proof of funds or if
you're a deal sourcer and you're and
you're trying to find a deal on behalf
of an investor
show the agent the investors proof of
funds build a relationship and if you
can do that with estate agents if they
know exactly what you're looking for
okay and if they know you're serious
they'll pass you deals before they even
go on right move this is absolutely
beautiful when it happens I get agents
calling me all the time sometimes I'll
just ring an agent and I'll say oh I'm
ringing about such and such a property I
say oh it's sold and I'll say oh that's
really annoying listen would it be right
if I tell you a bit about what I'm
looking for and then if anything else
comes up you can let me know they'll say
sure I'll start telling them what I'm
looking for and so often they'll say you
know what I haven't got the keys yet but
there's a property that's not on the
market that we've been instructed on um
in such and such a straight sounds like
it might be perfect for you
the estate agent will say that if they
know you're serious if you have a
relationship with them so that's the
second way to get off Market deals
through estate agents number three is
networking your network really is your
net worth and let me tell you something
if you go around to property networking
events where there's developers tired
landlords agents and you just build
relationships rather than trying to
pitch pitch pitch or trying to get a
deal build relationships there's a lot
of property developers that are building
hundreds or even thousands of new build
homes sometimes they don't even want to
have to put them on the market you can
buy them off Market Off plan at a
discount just because you put an offer
forward early this is the power of
networking it's not just what you know
it's also who you know when I was 17
years old I joined a a company called
business networking International I
joined four networking member member of
Commerce all these networking
associations I just stand up every time
I'd be having a breakfast over over the
networking event you have 20 seconds to
pitch I say hey I'm looking for a
property investment opportunities if you
know anyone that's selling their
property let me know I'm the guy and
there was so many business owners
developers agents that started passing
me stuff just because they knew who I
was number four online portals there's
so many online portals like Facebook
marketplace where owners before they put
their property on the market if they
want to sell they'll list the property
that they want to sell on these sites
themselves like Gumtree like Craigslist
let me tell you something as well for
someone to put their property on Gumtree
they kind of have to be pretty motivated
to sell it and it's not on the right
move it's not on the open market it
hasn't got anywhere near the level of
eyeballs that it would if they put it on
with a High Street agent so search these
sites relentlessly every day scroll
through look on Facebook Marketplace
Gumtree Craigslist look at these types
of online portals see what's selling and
then all you have to do pick up the
phone speak to the seller and just say
hey I've noticed that your property's
been on Gumtree for a few weeks I'm an
investor what's the lowest you'd be able
to accept and still live with if else to
buy cash tomorrow bang that's how you
get off Market discounted deals number
five and lastly is advertise if you
treat your business serious like a
business and not a side hustle you'll
have no problem putting a little bit of
money into your advertising marketing
campaigns we've spent thousands and
thousands of pounds doing Facebook ads
um for instance this is what we do that
works really really well back in 2018 we
put an advert and the advert said if you
are looking to sell your house and you
want to get your house valued free
valuation put the details in below and
if you're looking to sell we can give
you a value and then anyone that sees
that that's interested in selling the
house will click it we'll pay Facebook
every time someone clicks through I
think I think we're paying about 50
pence but if you've got 150 people that
have done that how much are you paying
75 pounds to have 150 people that are
saying I'm looking to sell my house
could you value it and then sure you go
on zoopla you go on Mouse price you go
on the different sites you look at
comparables you spend 10 minutes on it
you then send them through a free
valuation and say hey your house is
worth 300 000 pounds if you're looking
to sell it though I could buy cash for
220. I mean how many people do you need
to say yes before you've suddenly bagged
a below market value deal that's just
one type of advertising you can also put
little notes up on shop Windows looking
for houses if you're looking to sell We
Buy Houses fast We Buy Houses for cash
that's another way to find off Market
deals I'm sure there's way more ways to
find off-market deals if you've got
other ideas how you can find and bag
property Investments completely off the
market I'd love to hear your creative
ideas and suggestions comment it below
in the comments and I'll maybe included
in a future video I hope you found this
video helpful remember there is not a
shortage of good deals out there there's
just a shortage of investors that know
how to find them I'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]